dear friends I am thankful to United
Europe for that constant support that
Ukraine has been receiving since the
first hours of the Russian invasion
please know that your defense assistance
as well as Financial political and
humanitarian support saved millions of
lives this is the solidarity that
clearly demonstrates the strengths of
the European values when Europe is truly
United not a single tyranny can take the
freedom of the Europeans away the
economic basis of our defense is vital
for our survival
by starting the full-scale war Russia
blocked our pores on the Black Sea and
the Sea of azove a bigger part of
Ukrainian export and the import have
stopped but
we were able to open a new way of
economic life through the territory of
the European Union
along this road of life we established a
supply that is critically important not
only for Ukraine but also for the whole
Europe and many other countries partners
of Europe firstly it is agricultural
export more than 10 million tons of food
products have been exported across our
borders with the EU and through the
Danube ports thanks
to the Black Sea grain initiative 10
million tons of grain we are also
exported by sea this is a significant
contribution to Global Food Security on
the if of the half year anniversary of
the solidarity lands initiative I
confirm our Readiness to continue
working together with you in order to
further strengthen our Europe strengthen
economically and socially to strengthen
our state our companies our people and
to strengthen our European Union
slavocrine